[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDERS KLEINFELD: Jonny, I
just wanted to ask you first,
can you tell us a little bit
about the genesis of your book
and your alter ego on the
screen there, Jonny Sun?
JONNY SUN: Sure, yeah.
First of all, thanks
for having me.
And thanks for coming, everyone.
Yeah, sure.
I guess it's inspired
by my work on Twitter.
I started my Twitter account
when I moved to the US.
In Toronto, I was involved
in the comedy scene.
And I had a lot of
friends who were comedians
and writers and stuff.
And when I moved to the US, I
lost touch with that community,
I guess.
And so I turned to the
internet, and I found Twitter.
And I found this weird
subculture of Twitter comedy
called "weird Twitter,"
which was just
a bunch of anonymous accounts
posting surreal jokes
and poetry and stuff.
And I sort of turned to that
as a place to be creative
and to continue writing
humor and telling jokes when
I was in architecture school.
And I've been doing that
for the first six years now,
and I've sort of treated
Twitter as my writer's notebook,
in a sense.
And after a while, I moved here.
I started my PhD at MIT.
And I got really
anxious and depressed
and overwhelmed with
the program here.
And I needed some sort of
creative outlet, I think,
to sort of center myself.
And so I turned to Twitter,
and I looked at the notes
that I put on there.
And I started realizing
that all those tweets start
to create a story and start
to create a narrative that
eventually became this book.
SANDERS KLEINFELD:
Your alter ego
specifically-- how did
that vision of that alien
come about?
JONNY SUN: Well, it kind of goes
to the Twitter anonymity thing
as well.
In weird Twitter, this
place that I started,
a lot of the accounts
were anonymous.
And there were things like
famous crab or a cool ghost
or a ghost with sunglasses
or something like that.
And I found that an
alien sort of made sense
as a natural character for
me because I had always
felt like an outsider
my entire life.
I think a lot of my
comedy and my perspective
is based on this
sense of outsiderness.
And I think that's a great
comic perspective to have
and a very fruitful one.
And so it sort of just
happened naturally.
And I was a literal alien
being a Canadian the US.
And so I think all of
that got wrapped up
into this character
pretty neatly.
And then, by the time
the book came around,
I had realized that the story
of outsiderness and alienness
was something really
important to talk about.
And so I wanted to tell like
an alien invasion story,
not from the perspective
of the Earthlings,
but from the alien
who is invading,
and draw a lot of
empathy, and tell
the internal story of a
visitor coming to a new place,
and relate that to
my own experiences
and what was going
on at that time.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: I know it's
billed as a work of humor,
but it's very emotionally
resonant and poignant
throughout.
And I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about striking that balance
between being funny,
but also tugging at
emotional heartstrings
when you're writing.
JONNY SUN: Right, yeah.
One of the biggest reasons
why I love comedy so much
is because I think
it's a way in to having
these other
conversations and to be
able to speak to other
emotions and speak
to other sides of the human
psyche and of humanity.
And so I think my
favorite comedy growing up
has always been the
ones that balance humor
and a little bit of darkness,
or humor and other things,
and use humor as a tool
to talk about other ideas.
And so for me, I've always been
really excited about the fact
that you can get someone
on your page with a joke
and then start to have
another conversation.
The humor works as a tool
to disarm and to empathize
with someone else.
And then once you sort of
Trojan horse your way in,
you're able to talk
about other things.
And so for me, the
internet was a place
where I learned to be open about
mental health, for example.
And I learned to talk
about a lot of my anxiety
and depression in open ways.
Because on Twitter, I had
found these communities
that were talking
about this stuff
in open, constructive ways.
And it was kind of a
totally different experience
than "the real world,"
quote unquote, where
a lot of, I think, these
conversations around anxiety
and mental health are
still stigmatized.
People sort of tiptoe
around it, and it's
a strange conversation,
whereas online, I
think there were
places and there
were people and
communities that we
were talking about this openly
and using humor as a tool,
I think, to address it.
And so I wanted to bring
a lot of that sensibility
into the book.
On one page, you'll
get a really dumb pun.
And on the next page, I hope
that it explores these deeper
ideas.
SANDERS KLEINFELD:
What's interesting
is that Jonny the
alien comes to Earth
to learn about the humans.
But we don't see any
humans in the actual--
spoiler alert-- no humans
in the actual graphic novel.
But what you do see is all these
different animal characters
that are dealing with very
human emotional issues
around anxiety, imposter
syndrome to a certain degree,
the anxiety of an artist with
the otter who's also an auteur.
JONNY SUN: That's one of
the dumb puns, by the way.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: But
it's sort of interesting
that, in some ways, it becomes
even more resonant when
you put it through personas
because all this stuff is
so stigmatized.
So I was wondering if you had
any thoughts about exploring
human emotions in that way.
JONNY SUN: Yeah, absolutely.
In essence, the book is
extremely autobiographical.
And each animal becomes a
symbol of each thread of stuff
that I'm working through.
And so there is a character
that I split off that talks
about my feelings of
imposter syndrome being here
in Cambridge and being at
MIT and being surrounded
by all these brilliant
people and feeling
like I don't belong.
One of my favorite
characters is a hedgehog
because the hedgehog
struggles with the idea of how
to make art or how to make
something while feeling totally
unable to do so.
And I wrote that
character in while I
was writing the book
because I was trying
to grapple with my feelings
of writing the book as I
was writing the book.
And so that became the character
that went through that.
I think the power of
using animals and using
symbols and characters
and metaphors is--
it kind of goes back to this
idea of what humor does, too.
I think both of these are
ways to filter conversations
that are more difficult to have
and filter them into easier
ways to digest them and allow
those conversations to be had
in ways that doesn't make
someone immediately step back
and become guarded.
I think it's easier
to talk about anxiety
through a cute alien character
than to walk up to someone
and be like, I'm really anxious.
Help me.
I need to unload all
this stuff, which
is I think part of why
I'm interested in using
these symbols and these
characters in this way.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: Are any
of the themes in the book
the same things you're exploring
in your doctoral research?
JONNY SUN: Sort of, yeah.
The other element of
the book that I really
love talking about
is structurally,
I'm really interested
in the book as this way
to distill a social media
narrative or this idea of how
we read the internet.
And I wanted to think about--
this book, for example,
it's about an alien
who comes to Earth
and then meets
all these different
characters and gets
little updates from each of
the characters interspersed
throughout.
So on one page,
there's a beaver.
On one page, there's a tree.
On one page, there's an egg.
And then it goes
back to the beaver.
And then it jumps
to the egg again.
It's kind of this very
scrambled timeline, which
if you think about a traditional
kid's book in this form,
I always think about "Winnie the
Pooh," where all the characters
are divided into chapters.
And so there is a
chapter for the owl,
and you get the whole owl story.
And there's a
chapter for Eeyore,
and you get all
of Eeyore's story.
But in this book, I wanted
to do away with the chapters
and think about how
you could scramble
all those different pieces of
the story amongst each other.
And to me, that's how we
read social media now.
That's sort of the
Twitter timeline,
in an essence, where
I go on Twitter,
and I follow 100 people.
And then I get all their
updates interspersed throughout.
And the book was
this test to see
if that type of narrative
format could still
work in a traditional medium.
So that was really fun.
And that kind of relates to
my dissertation research,
which is primarily about how
social media forms community
and how different people
can come together and find
each other online.
And I think that's sort of
what the book, both formally
and content-wise, is about.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: Right.
So you talked a lot about
the positive aspects
of finding community online.
There's an anonymity
aspect to it
where you can sort of
create your own persona.
But there's also obviously
a dark side to that as well.
So do you have
thoughts on that--
where things are going
well in terms of community
and how we can ameliorate
some of these issues?
Twitter-- it's this
timeline of positive stuff.
And then all of
a sudden, there's
this toxic brew underneath the
surface that comes bubbling up.
JONNY SUN: Yeah.
I think it's something
that anyone on Twitter
has to grapple with
and has to deal with.
I've seen it firsthand.
And I've seen a lot
of my friends deal
with the dog piling and
the bad side of Twitter
and the alt-right and the white
supremacists and the Nazis.
And if I keep
talking about this,
I'll get really depressed.
But I think it's
absolutely something that
needs to be addressed.
One of the things I've
been thinking about a lot
recently is how a lot of
the community-forming tools
and the ways that a lot of the
good stuff happens on Twitter
is sort of almost
the same technique
that the bad side will take and
use to do their work as well.
And so I think a lot
right now about this idea
that platforms and
technologies are neutral.
And this way that Twitter steps
back from any of the problems
going on in the
platform by saying,
oh, we don't have a say
in how people use it.
We're just going to
let people use it--
that's a political
stance in itself.
And I think it caused
a lot of problems.
And I think the next step for
this mentality about technology
is to say that these
platforms are not neutral
and that we need
to take a stronger
stance in how people use them
and what they're used for.
SANDERS KLEINFELD:
To a certain extent,
too, the platforms
and the technology
set the rules of engagement.
So on Twitter, for example,
because most people choose
to do public feeds in order
to get their message out,
and these systems that
are in place that let
anybody mention each other--
it creates an environment
where you can have
those sorts of interactions.
So I'm wondering
if in your research
you looked into any ways
that technology mediates
the interactions
that we have and what
are good choices to make
in order to support that.
JONNY SUN: Well, it's
something that I'm definitely
interested in researching.
Just off the top
of my head, I've
been really interested
in how Twitter
seems to be the place where all
this conversation is happening
now.
And it's sort of a place where
all of this community building
is happening now as opposed
to the other big social media
platforms, like
Instagram and Facebook.
If you look at
Instagram, for example,
there's not really a way for
two people to interact directly.
Instagram is a much more
broadcast-type platform,
where you post a thing,
and then other people
can comment on the thing.
It's much harder to have
a one-to-one conversation
on Instagram, which
is why I think
community doesn't form in the
way that it does on Twitter.
But on Twitter, you're right.
It's all public.
And now with the
quote tweets, I think
there's a way to broadcast ideas
in ways that are not strictly
one-to-one.
If I quote tweet someone,
I've noticed actually a lot--
I've stopped doing
this for this reason.
Because if I quote tweet
someone who I don't like
or has said something
mean to me in some way,
I've noticed that a
lot of my followers
will then take
that as permission
to start dog piling this
critic of mine, for example.
And it creates a more
toxic environment
where if I say, oh, you
can all see this person
and you can now respond to
this person, a lot of people
will start to
respond badly, right?
I've stopped doing it because
I think it's not the right way
to do it.
I don't know what the right way
to have a good discourse is.
But I know plenty of wrong
ways from experiencing
both sides of it.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: I was
talking to some friends
late last week about
when we're interacting
with each other in person,
there are certain rules
of etiquette and
certain moral standards
that we uphold just by nature of
seeing a person in front of us
and recognizing their humanity.
And it's interesting.
When we go online, we
can craft our own persona
and our own humanity
the way we want.
But we sometimes
fail to recognize
other people's humanity.
We think it's OK to
talk in a certain way
that we would
never do in person.
So I'm wondering
if there is a way
to bring that aspect of humanity
into these virtual communities
where it's really up in your
face, hey, this is a person.
JONNY SUN: Right, yeah.
I've been thinking a
lot about that, too.
I think Twitter gets a lot
of criticism because of its
short-handedness and
the fact that in 200--
it used to be 140, now 280--
characters, it's still hard for
people to get a full story in.
I think people are
trying really hard
to work within those
confines to be nuanced
and to have more of a full
picture to what they're saying.
And that's through threading.
And that's through these
longer conversations
that they're having
on the medium.
But I think it's
really difficult.
And I think it's a
lot easier to not
recognize the person
you're talking
to on the other side of the
screen is a person, because you
just see a text handle
and a bio and an image,
as opposed to a person
sitting on a screen typing
this stuff out.
And I don't know how to
address that, really,
because I don't know if the
solution is to give everyone
pictures of who they are and
allow everyone to see exactly
who it is they're talking to.
Because they think
anonymity has been
really powerful in a lot of good
ways in terms of, for example,
political dissent, where the
most marginalized communities
and the most targeted members
of certain communities
can't put their real
identities out there
and can't speak against
power by putting
their real faces online.
And so I think anonymity is a
great way for those communities
and for members of those
communities to have a voice
and to have a say.
And so I don't know.
I think it's such a big problem.
And I think we're right
in the middle of it,
and I think it's super messy.
I'm just as curious
as to anyone on how
it's all going to turn out.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: You
recently put together
Tiny Care Bot, which
is just a bot that
tweets self-care
messages for people
to engage with them
on that human level.
It's interesting
that in some ways,
technology can even be more
humane than the people using it
when applied.
I'm curious what
kind of uptake you've
seen on that and
response from people.
Do they like a bot
tweeting at them
saying you should drink more
water and things like that?
JONNY SUN: Yeah.
So Tiny Care Bot is this
really simple bot that I made.
It sends hourly reminders of
little actionable self-care
tools.
And I built it, actually,
for me personally to use.
I built it in November
of 2016 because something
happened during that time
that made me really upset.
And it kept me on Twitter a lot.
And I found that days after,
for the whole week or a while
after the election, I was glued
to Twitter because I thought
that getting updates and
seeing all this stuff
would somehow help me
understand what was going on.
I was caught in this cycle of
just being stuck to my phone
and stuck to the
news and everything.
And at some point, I
realized I needed to get off.
And I needed to take
care of myself better.
And so ironically, I built
this thing on the platform
that I was using to tell
me to get off of it.
And I built it
because I wanted it
to show up in between
all the other updates.
I thought the best
way to enact change
was to have an agent
on the same platform
that I was sort of
stuck on right now.
And I built that, and
then I tweeted about it.
I think it was the right time
and the right sort of types
of self-care actions
that it related
to a lot of other
people as well.
And it's absolutely not the
first self-care bot on Twitter.
And it's not the first
one that anyone's done.
But I think at that point
and the specific types
of tweets it was
tweeting made it really
resonate with a lot of people.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: It's good.
We need more messages telling
us when we should engage,
when we should
disengage, I think,
because it can really
be overwhelming.
You want to read
some of your book?
JONNY SUN: Sure, yeah.
Let's do a reading.
Do people have copies
of the book right now?
I like to do it as a
read-along for anyone who
has a copy of the book.
And if not, the slides
are up here, too.
So we can do that as well.
But let's start
on the first page
if you have a copy of the book.
It's the page with
the four UFOs on it.
Whoosh.
In comes a spaceship, carrying
the night sky with it.
Wobble wobble, screech, thump.
The spaceship lands.
Out come a bunch of aliens.
Please find out about
the Earth creatures,
says the first alien.
Humans, says the second
alien, pointing to a bird.
Yes, humans, says
the third alien,
pointing to a tuft of grass.
Take your time.
Really, take as much time as
you need, says the fourth alien.
So you're leaving me here
all alone, asks Jomny.
Well, we'll check up on you
in case you mess anything
up, says the fifth alien.
OK, says Jomny, still worried.
Can we go already, says the
sixth alien, already bored
of this planet.
And so off they go, taking
the night sky with them
as they leave.
"Everyone's a Aliebn
When Ur a Aliebn, Too--
A Book."
Jomny walks along and
happens upon a tree.
Hello.
Are you a Earth
creature, Jomny asks.
Yes, says the tree.
I have met a human, says Jomny,
contentedly walking away.
Jomny sees a snail and
kneels down and says,
tell me about yourself, to which
the snail responds, oh, gee.
Well, nobody's ever
asked me about myself.
Well, I guess
everybody tells me I'm
too small and too slow to make
a difference in this world.
But I'm making a
difference in my own world,
and I hope that's enough.
Jomny comes up to a bear
and starts poking the bear.
Wow, you're big, says Jomny,
not knowing what a bear is.
Are you going to run screaming
from me then, asks the bear.
No, says Jomny, continuing
to poke the bear.
Oh, thank you, says the bear.
Meanwhile, all the
other Earth creatures
are running away from the bear.
And the turtle screams, run!
Run as fast as you can!
Faster!
Save yourselves!
Leave me behind and
save yourselves!
Run, R-U-N, run, says
one particular bee.
Jomny keeps walking
and comes across a dog.
And the dog says a word that
can roughly be translated
to the symbol of a heart.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I do not understand that
word, says Jomny, but OK.
Jomny comes across an egg.
Hello, what are you, asks Jomny.
I don't know yet, says the egg.
OK, says Jomny.
Isn't that exciting, says the
egg, shaking with excitement.
Jomny comes across a hedgehog
and asks, who are you?
Oh, I'm an introvert, which is
different from an extrovert,
says the hedgehog.
What's that, Jomny asks.
Well, introverts
enjoy people-watching.
Extroverts enjoy
people watching.
It's a grammar joke.
[LAUGHING]
OK, says Jomny, looking
at a flower, who he
decides must be an extrovert.
The flower has the
attention of all the bees
and is saying, oh, yeah,
bees, you like this?
You like what I got?
You like what you see?
Because there's plenty
of me to go around.
And one particular
bee says, hi, H-I, hi.
Jomny comes across a pond.
Swim, splash.
You swim very nicely,
says Jomny to the otter.
Of course.
I'm an auteur, says the otter.
Hello, otter, says Jomny.
Swim, swim.
The otter rises.
No, wait.
I'm an auteur, says the
otter, trying to clarify.
Jomny comes across
a smaller pond
and sees a bunch of
smaller creatures.
Hello, who are you, Jomny asks.
It's not about who we are.
It's about what we will
become, says the caterpillar.
That's the gift of being
a baby, says the tadpole.
Isn't it exciting, says the egg
again, shaking with excitement.
Jomny thinks of the idea of a
gift and goes up to the tree
and asks, what is a gift?
Can I have a gift?
And the tree says,
oh, I actually
learned to stop giving
things to somebody
just because they
want something.
The tree frowns knowingly.
I don't think that
would end well for me.
Jomny asks, what if
I give you a hug?
And the tree says,
oh, I love hugs.
But really, you don't
have to give me anything
to be my friend.
What's a friend, asks Jomny.
A friend is anyone or anything
who shares a life with you
that you would never be able
to experience without them,
says the tree.
Jomny thinks about this and
walks up to a bird and says,
hello, friend.
You used to be a dinosaur.
Then Jomny walks up to
a skeleton and says,
hello, friend.
You used to be a baby.
The tree pulls Jomny
aside and says, maybe
stay away from that friend.
OK, says Jomny.
Jomny comes across an onion.
And the onion says,
I'm like an onion.
Peel back the layers, and you'll
see that deep down inside, I'm
just a smaller,
more afraid onion.
But you are an onion,
says Jomny helpfully.
Yes, I know that.
But now I want to cry, says the
onion, feeling misunderstood.
Jomny comes across an owl
and says, hello, friend.
Who are you?
Who, who who, asked the owl.
Who am I?
I don't really know.
Everybody calls
me wise, and I've
tried to learn very
much about the world.
But I don't feel very wise.
And I know that owls
are supposed to be wise,
so then I don't feel
owl enough to be an owl.
I feel like one day,
I'll meet another owl.
And they'll take one look
at me and say, oh, somebody
made a mistake.
You're not supposed
to be an owl at all.
Anyway, who are
you, asked the owl.
I'm Jomny, says Jomny.
Oh, lucky, says the owl.
Jomny comes across the
bees again and asks,
will you be my friends?
And the bees say,
sorry, we can't.
We're afraid we'll
accidentally sting you.
Jomny comes across the
beaver and shouts, wait!
Hello, friend, as
the beaver runs by.
And the beaver
responds, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I have work to do.
I don't have time
to be your friend.
I'm sorry.
Can't you see I'm
in a hurry here?
The beaver's Canadian,
hence all the apologies.
The beaver runs past the tree.
And the tree says, oh, don't
bother with that dam beaver.
But I need to work,
says the beaver.
Please stay out of
my dam business.
Then please stop stealing my
branches, shouts the tree.
They're not yours,
shouts the beaver.
Yes they are, shouts the tree.
I'm sorry.
They're my dam branches
now, shouts the beaver.
Those are my arms,
shouts the tree.
What if I never
hatch, shouts the egg.
Or what if I do hatch, and it's
the best moment of my life,
but then I never
get to hatch again?
What if I want to hatch
but also never hatch?
Can I do both or neither?
Why are you so worried?
You're an egg, says Jomny.
That's not fair.
You already know who
you are, says the egg.
But your an egg, says
Jomny, trying to help.
The egg rolls over on its side.
You just don't get
it, says the egg.
Oh, says Jomny, sadly.
Jomny walks along and
sees the dog again.
And the dog says another word
that can roughly be translated
to the symbol of a heart.
I still do not know
what that means,
but I know that I'm
happy now, says Jomny.
Meanwhile, the spaceship
flies in again,
carrying the night sky with it.
Jomny runs up to the aliens
and says, I like the humans.
They're all so different, and I
wish I could be more like them.
You're not supposed to like
them, says the first alien.
You're supposed to research
them, says the second alien.
I do not like them,
says the third alien.
He should be more like
us, says the fourth alien.
He's already too weird,
says the fifth alien.
Yeah, says the sixth alien,
agreeing with the fifth alien.
The humans are weird,
says the seventh alien.
Yeah, says the eighth
alien, agreeing
with the seventh alien.
And so off they go
again, leaving Jomny
alone with the night
sky to contemplate.
And that's where we'll
stop the reading.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
SANDERS KLEINFELD: So we'll
open things up to questions now.
AUDIENCE: I liked what
you said about mixing
humor and darkness.
And that immediately
made me think
of "A Softer World" and maybe
a few other Canadian artists
specifically.
So I was wondering, you
mentioned the Canadian beaver
in here.
Do you feel, especially having
a bit of an outside perspective
spending a lot of time in the
US at this point, anything
particularly Canadian
about the work that you do
or the milieu that
you find yourself in?
JONNY SUN: Because I've grown
up Canadian and I am Canadian,
it's hard for me to sort of
see outside of myself a bit
to understand what it
is about the work that--
and people do respond
and say this makes sense
that someone Canadian wrote it.
And I'm not entirely sure
what element of it it is.
I think there is a bit more of
a kindness and a bit more of a--
I've heard this metaphor used
across Canada and the US,
where the US is a melting
pot, and Canada is a salad.
The idea in the US is that
everyone comes and is expected
to ameliorate into this
single American identity,
whereas in Canada, I think
that the approach is more
of a celebration of
all the differences
and of all the diverse pieces.
And I think
ultimately, the story
that I wanted to
tell in this book
is a celebration of all the
differences and the idea
that all these different
personalities and creatures
and personas can all
coexist and get along--
not by becoming the
same, but by celebrating
what's different about them.
So I think maybe
that's part of it.
And yeah, I really do
love "A Softer World."
And I grew up reading
that webcomic.
Yeah, I'm not entirely sure.
I think there is a bit
about perhaps Canadian--
I don't want to speak to a broad
thing, so I'm not going to.
But yeah, I don't know.
I'm not sure.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Jonny.
I just wanted to say
I really appreciate
how open you've been about
talking about mental illness.
But once your private
persona became more public,
did that change the way you
talked about it or the way
people in your life or
professional people treated you
or your own stigma
around your experience?
JONNY SUN: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
I think I definitely got--
let's see.
I think for a while, I didn't
have the right language
to talk about it.
And I didn't grow up
knowing that I, too, could
have anxiety and depression.
And I didn't know that
therapy, for example,
was an option for me until I
started reading about it online
and until I started befriending
people on the internet who
were talking about
therapy and talking
about mental health a lot.
So I think for me, a
lot of why I really
care about talking about
this stuff in a public way
is because I know
how much it helped me
when I didn't know
about it and when
I had a stigmatized internal
idea of what mental health was.
And so I think I'm trying
now to give back to--
I know a lot of people follow
me and see what I'm saying.
I'm trying to in my own
way continue to pass it on
and to continue to
destigmatize and normalize
these conversations.
But I definitely
think it's become--
because I'm so public
with it, I think
it's become something I have to
be really careful about, too.
And I never want to
say anything that
brings up any sort of
false stigmas or biases.
I think for the
most part, people
are really open and
kind about it in person,
because you asked about how
it affects me now in person.
And I think part of that is
self-selecting in the sense
that I don't want to be friends
with someone who is going
to be like, well, that's dumb.
Pull yourself up.
And I think it's
sort of interesting,
because I think the more
I've been open about it,
the more people
know that about me.
I think just the fact that
I am open about it opens up
the conversation
for other people.
And I think if I'm setting the
stage of how to talk about it,
I think it allows others to
come into that conversation
in a different way.
So I found it really
helpful for the most part,
but it's also really
scary all the time.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I was checking out
your Twitter earlier,
and I saw that you tweet
a lot of funny stuff.
JONNY SUN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I also used to try
to tweet funny stuff on Twitter
with some success and
a lot of failed tweets.
And I was just interested
in your perspective
on the tweet writing process
and when you think of a joke
or think of something that
you think could be funny--
because it also has
to fit the format.
And you have to phrase it
correctly and things like that.
And that makes a big difference,
especially when you have
so many followers and stuff--
how many people even see it.
So I was wondering
if you could just
comment on your methodology
and maybe give me some tips.
JONNY SUN: Yeah, absolutely.
First, to start off, I've
been on Twitter for so long.
Six or seven years
ago, I was tweeting
jokes with hashtags
at the end of it,
like so-and-so, #joke, #pun.
And it took me a while
to understand or fall
into a community
and understand how
to tell these jokes in a
way that suits the format
and works with the medium.
And I think the thing
that really switched
for me was when I stopped
just trying to tell
jokes to get jokes out there.
And it switched when I started
seeing this group of writers
that I looked up
to as a community.
Twitter became really fun for me
when I started realizing, oh, I
just want to make jokes with
these other people I admire.
And it sort of
became much more of--
it wasn't about getting views
or getting likes or whatever.
It was about, well, let's
riff off each other.
And let's treat this as
this big writer's room.
And I think that's when
I started really loving
it and finding that
all of us together
had come across
this type of joke
telling that people
appreciated in a way.
I think now, I'm very
conscious about how
Twitter humor is very different
from other forms of humor
and other mediums.
And even in trying to adapt
some of the jokes I wrote
on Twitter into the
book, there were a lot
that I just
immediately struck off.
I think on Twitter,
there's a lot
of value in the
real-time nature of it.
And I think that's one of the
strengths of Twitter humor--
is that you can comment on
stuff as it happens right away.
Easily, that's political
humor and stuff about politics
and current events.
But it's also just being
part of the conversation
as it's happening
and taking a meme
and restructuring it and
playing on it as it's fun
and in the ethos.
So one joke that I wanted
to put in the book was Jomny
looking at a cloud and being
like, how do I make friends?
And then a bigger cloud
shows up and says,
don't talk to me or
my son ever again.
And that obviously
doesn't make sense now
because that was like two
years old at this point.
Yeah, this guy gets it.
I think I wanted to make
sure that the book was less
connected to this real-time,
fast paced, constantly updating
type of humor that
Twitter is good at.
I also think Twitter has made
me a more conscious writer
in terms of
structure and format.
And I turned to
Twitter originally
because of the short format.
And it really allowed me
to strip away the extra
and to really figure
out what the joke was
and how to tell it properly.
And I think it's made me a
better writer in the sense
that I get to the
idea quicker, and I
get punchier and punchier.
I think one of the downfalls is
that now when I try to sit down
and write a longer piece, I
can write three tweets' worth
of ideas and be like, that's it.
That's the whole essay.
I don't need to write more.
But yeah, I hope that answers
part of your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it
definitely does.
I'll take some of
your tips to heart.
JONNY SUN: Cool.
Awesome.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: How's it been being
a creative, artistic person
with your art out there
and then also dealing
with the professional
world of graduate school?
How did your advisor or
colleagues or whatever
receive that you're writing
a book, being a Twitter
humorist, all of that stuff?
JONNY SUN: Right.
I think luckily, I've found--
again, it's like that
self-selecting idea.
But I think I found
advisors who understand
what it is that I'm
trying to do on Twitter
and are deeply supportive of it.
My thought in terms of how do
I merge this creative pursuit
with an academic pursuit is what
sorts of learning experiences
do I have in this
online world in practice
that I can look at
in an academic way
or that helps inform
me on how to have
an academic
conversation about it.
I'm sure there are a lot
of professors and people
in the academic world who
are like, this is dumb.
They don't get it.
But I've been lucky enough that
my advisors really understand
it and are really
supportive of it.
So yeah, that's
been really great.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
JONNY SUN: Thanks.
Actually, I do want to add, too.
I think this type of
study, the sociological
study of the internet and of
internet culture and media
studies, that type of thing, is
getting more and more traction
now.
When I started at MIT, I wanted
to look at data-driven cities
and understand like
urban processes
through big data, which is
totally different than where
I've ended up, which is network
cultures and the study of media
and internet and community.
And it really is
because at MIT, there
were a few comparative media
studies classes that directly
talked about internet culture
and memes and all the stuff
that we're talking about now.
And it was just cool to me that
there were people studying it.
And I think there's been a
huge community I found that has
been really interested.
I'm part of the
Berkman Klein center.
It's the Berkman Klein Center
of Internet and Society
over at Harvard.
And they're really interested
in the confluence of internet
and society and politics
and activism and AI
and all these human elements
that compose the internet.
And so I think it's
really cool that there
are people and pockets that are
really interested in this type
of stuff.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You were talking
about anonymity on Twitter
and some of the
other social media
networks and its
influence on poor behavior
and how maybe humanizing
it would help with that.
I'm curious why you
believe that's the case.
Here at Google,
we've got a bunch
of internal social
networks, and it's
100% known who everybody is.
People still opt out
of showing faces.
They still shitpost.
They still troll.
Even face-to-face, I think
about watching conversations
around here.
And you like to think that
you'll treat people as more
human because its face-to-face.
And people will still treat
each other pretty badly
on an ongoing basis--
the coworkers they spend
all their time with.
So why do you think humanizing
the internet would help?
JONNY SUN: I think
being able to see
that the people you're
interacting with
are three-dimensional people
is the basis of any sort
of empathetic conversation
and empathetic connection
to that person.
And I think that
forms the basis of how
I believe we can move forward.
I think there's such
a divide right now.
And I'm not saying
go make friends
with someone who is targeting
you and who wants you
and everyone who you identify
with to be killed or something.
But I think on a
day-to-day level,
it helps build community.
The communities that
I've found on Twitter
have been really helpful
for me because of the fact
that they are just
a lot of people
humanizing and empathizing
with each other.
I think the question
of anonymity
is different when you talk
about a general completely
accessible-- or not
completely accessible,
but a general platform
like Twitter where
anyone from anywhere could
have a voice as opposed
to somewhere like
Google, which is
a self-selected kind of group.
In a place like a workplace,
I think anonymity is still
valuable in certain ways.
But I think there's less
of a danger associating
what you say with your face.
I think if you're
online and you're
like a member of a
very persecuted group,
you can't really put your
face on what you're saying,
or else people will find
you and identify you.
And I think that
sort of danger isn't
present in a place of employment
perhaps, or less dangerous.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
a tenant of faith
that humanizing the internet
will somehow solve this.
We've tried the
experiment and found--
I don't think it did.
So I'm curious, since you're
doing PhD research on this,
was there any evidence?
Or is it just a tenant
of faith at this point?
JONNY SUN: Right now it's an
unsubstantiated hypothesis.
I'm super curious to
see how it plays out.
And I'd love to talk
to you more about it.
I've just finished my
PhD exams, and so I'm
going into the research mode.
And so this is actually--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So actually, this is
the right point for me
to really figure out what
the research is going to be.
And so I'm excited and
happy to talk more about it.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jonathan.
Thank you so much for taking the
time to answer our questions.
I'm Snow, and I do
drawings and some painting.
And so I'm curious about
your artistic work process.
So you mentioned that you
are an artist slash a writer.
So could you just talk
about your experience
with art, what led
you to this project,
and what kind of
artistic inspiration
or creative decision
you made that were
fundamental to this project?
JONNY SUN: Sure.
Yeah, absolutely.
I'd love to talk about that.
I've grown up drawing and
being involved in visual design
and trying to learn different
methods of communication
through a visual medium.
And for a while, I was really
into painting and street
art and these very lush,
detailed drawings and graphics
and processes.
And when I went to
architecture school,
I actually got really
into technical drawing
and like these very detailed 3D
axonometric intricate things.
And so I had all
that under my belt
and in my head when I
started thinking about what
this book would look like.
And I really wanted to
make a conscious effort
to step back from that
and to minimalize it
as much as possible and
to make the characters as
simple as possible--
almost resembling icons
more than characters--
and finding the
balance between how
do you make this
simple, relatable icon
image while still
giving that icon enough
character and enough humanity
and enough relatability,
I guess, to be a character.
And so that's sort
of where I landed.
For example, the aesthetic
language of this book
is no corners.
Everything is curves, right?
And I really tried to
make it as bubbly and as
soft-looking as possible.
And some of the fun details,
like even Jomny the character--
I'm just looking at it now--
there is a little bit of
formal structure to him
because he's three circles, the
belly and the two circles that
comprise the bean.
And the rule that
I used internally
was the two circles
that comprise the head--
the distance that they
overlap is the same distance
that the body circle is
away from the second circle.
And so there's a little bit
of a math formula involved
in that, which is my
architecture background coming
out.
But for the most part,
I tried to keep it
as simple-looking as possible.
And I found that's
been really cool.
And black and white
thing has been cool too
because people on Twitter
have started coloring the book
and sharing with me.
And for me, seeing how other
people interpret the book
and how they color it
has been really cool,
because it sort of makes it
theirs as much as it is mine.
It sort of creates
this cool connection.
So yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I'm just making notes here on
the geometric deconstruction
of the alien.
No, actually, I'm
just here to thank you
for leaving us this book as a
timeless artifact as opposed
to Twitter, which is this, as
you said, very in the moment
artifact.
And they both provide
different benefits.
But this at least is
something that you
can return to later without
necessarily all that context.
And I wanted to pass
along the best book
review of this
which I've gotten,
which I got from my
kids, specifically
my daughter, who
was 6 at the time.
After we had read a
few pages together,
and then I'd let them each
go off with it for a bit,
she came back to me and very
earnestly, very urgently said,
Dad, this book is
full of feelings.
And so I just wanted to
pass that along to you.
Thank you so much.
JONNY SUN: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
That's so sweet.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So just
from the way you talk,
I imagine Canada is
such a wonderful place.
So why did you leave?
And what do you have to say
to people like me who actually
want to move to Canada?
What kind of advice
could you give me?
JONNY SUN: I never want to
fall into the danger of saying
Canada's this perfect
utopia, because it isn't.
There are a lot of
things that Canada
needs to work on as well--
for example, its treatment
of indigenous peoples.
I find myself asking
that question a lot--
why did I leave Canada--
especially in these
last two years.
And I think I'll always
see Canada as my home.
And I've always intended
to go back there.
I think myself and a lot of
Canadian students who end up
in the US have
done it because we
want to go to a school in
the States, essentially.
That's the strongest reason
I can come up with for now.
I need to be here because
I'm going to school here.
But at the same time,
I've been here long enough
that I've really made a
lot of American friends
and seen what is
happening in the US.
And I've become really
invested in the politics here
and in everything
that's happening.
And I really care
about my friends
who are people of color who are
getting persecuted in the US
and who have to live
in fear all the time.
And so it's given me a lot
to empathize with here.
It's become a place where
I've fallen in love with
but also am deeply
critical and sad about.
But I think, ultimately,
it's become a country that
used to just be like,
oh, this is the country
south of where I am.
Now it's sort of
like my second home.
And now I really care
about what happens here
and about my
friends who are here
and the people who are here.
So now I feel this weird
split between understanding
that I'm Canadian
and being Canadian,
but also deeply being invested
in the outcome of this country.
AUDIENCE: So first of all,
thanks for being hopeful.
You ever want to no
longer be an alien?
JONNY SUN: Do I ever want
to no longer be an alien?
No, I don't think so.
First of all, I don't
know if that's my decision
to make, first of all.
But I think I've been
really happy with
or I've grown comfortable with
being placed as an outsider
and seeing myself
as an outsider.
And I think there is a
lot of value in that.
I think being an
outsider to most things
allows you to be critical in a
way that is harder to see when
you're ingrained in that thing.
Yeah, I don't know.
I kind of like it for now.
And I think the best
thing about it is that--
I think someone
once described me
as a public lonely person
or something like that.
And I think the kind of
beauty about publicly
saying that is that I
find other people who
also feel like aliens and
who feel like outsiders.
And together, we form this
community of outsiders,
and we find a connection.
And that's really sweet.
It never goes from
a group of outsiders
to one group of insiders.
It's always just this lovely
diverse group of other people.
And I think that's really
nice, and I really value that.
So yeah, I think
we should all be--
that sounds cheesy.
I'm not even going to say it.
I'm not even going to say I
think we should all be aliens.
But I think there's
a value to that.
And I think I'm really happy
with my place within that.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: So I heard
you made an announcement
about an upcoming next project.
JONNY SUN: Oh, yeah.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: Do you
want to tell everybody
about that really quickly?
JONNY SUN: Sure.
The next book I'm
working on is a book
with Lin-Manuel Miranda, who
is the creator of "Hamilton"
and "In the Heights,"
among other things.
And I'm actually really
excited about it.
It's called "Gmorning,
Gnight," and it's
a compilation of Lin's good
morning and goodnight tweets
that are from Twitter.
And basically, we compiled them.
And I've done illustrations
for each good morning
and good night tweet.
And it's this very
sweet, cute book
that hopefully does something
similar to what this book does
in the sense that it creates
this object that people can
really hold onto and
that is full of feelings
and that I think
is this hopeful,
kind of empathetic object.
And yeah, I'm really,
really excited about it.
It comes out
October 23, so yeah.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: We
will be on the lookout.
JONNY SUN: Absolutely.
SANDERS KLEINFELD: Thank you so
much for coming again, Jonny.
JONNY SUN: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]